to the Supreme Court now where justices
will hear arguments today over President
Biden's plan to forgive student loan
debt for more than 40 million Americans
opponents say that Mr Biden has taken
his presidential Powers too far and for
now the program is on hold until the
justices make a decision Jan Crawford is
at the Supreme Court for us Jan good
morning
well good morning Tony you know this is
one of the bigger cases this term it's
another clash between Republicans and
President Biden who made it a campaign
promise to address student loan debt but
the question is whether he went about it
the right way or whether on an issue
this big involving nearly half a
trillion dollars that Congress has to
sign off now under the plan up to 43
million people would be eligible for
some student loan debt relief people
making less than 125 thousand dollars a
year could see ten thousand dollars in
debt forgiven and people who got Pell
Grants could get up to twenty thousand
dollars for given the Congressional
budget office says the program will cost
more than 430 billion dollars after
President Biden announced the plan last
August 26 million people applied before
lower courts put it all on hold now
today the justices will hear two
different challenges one is by Six
republican-led States who say the
program will cost them money and in
court papers they say it's a quote
breathtaking and transformative extra
exercise of power the other case is by
two students who say the program should
do more to relieve student debt now the
president himself initially insisted
this was an issue for Congress and that
he couldn't do it alone but when
Congress failed to act he had a change
of heart and today his lawyer will argue
that federal law does Grant him that
power it is unclear when the justices
will rule on this but we expect a
decision at some point by the end of
June Nate
Jan thank you